thanks to backblaze for keeping legal
eagle in the air or cloud
backed up in the cloud president trump
uses his pardon power and commutes roger
stone's
sentence i'm getting rave reviews for
what i did for
roger stone is there anything to be done
are there limits to this pardon power
as you may recall roger stone is proud
to call himself a dirty trickster stone
has been around
since the nixon era but he found his
true home as an advisor to president
donald trump
and last year stone was convicted of
obstruction of justice giving false
statements to congress
and witness tampering stemming from the
findings of special counsel robert
mueller's probe into russian election
interference
and last week president trump commuted
roger stone's three-year
sentence this is in stark contrast to
the two individuals who have offered
testimony
against the president lieutenant
commander alexander vinman whose
military career is now over
and michael cohen who is now in prison
roger stone
lied for the president and now
theoretically at least he is free
did president trump do anything illegal
in this instance and could legislators
pass a law to limit the president's
power
well let's find out
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because at least
one of the president's confidants is
probably not going to jail
now before we talk about the legality of
the commutation of roger stone's
sentence and what that
actually means let's talk about what
roger stone actually did that
theoretically was going to send him to
jail in the first place
now a lot of americans still have the
perception that the mueller
investigation was
a political wish hunt i can't imagine
where they got that from
but it's worth recalling just how
important the inquiry was into the 2016
election and how
roger stone's lies helped protected the
president
now a lot of this information was
already public record but a good portion
of it was just conveyed to congress by
aaron zielenski
the us attorney who prosecuted roger
stone you might recall that attorney
general barr filed a memorandum
effectively retracting zielinski's
recommendation that roger stone served
a serious prison term as a result of the
obstruction of justice-related charges
and zielinski withdrew in protest and
then testified before
congress but going back even further
based on zolensky's testimony and the
mueller report itself you might recall
that in 2016 u.s intelligence agencies
determined that russian president
vladimir putin
wanted to damage hillary clinton's
election chances putin wanted to convey
damaging information
about the clinton campaign and wanted
that information to come from a source
that had the appearance of authenticity
so putin selected wikileaks because of
the perception that wikileaks was a
righteous truth-teller rather than
a front for any government or political
party u.s intelligence said that
wikileaks was being used by russia's gru
that assessment was confirmed by other
western intelligence agencies including
the british
now during the 2016 election the russian
government conspired with wikileaks to
influence u.s elections by hacking
accounts belonging to the democratic
national committee
hillary clinton and her advisor john
podesta the computer attacks on the
clinton campaign operatives were in fact
considered federal crimes and that is
one of the indictments that came out as
a result of the mueller investigation
under federal law it is illegal to hack
someone's email and social media
accounts
and the mueller investigation led to the
russians who were involved in the
computer hacks being indicted under
federal crimes though
since they're not in the u.s it's
unlikely that they will actually be
prosecuted
and on june 14 2016 the dnc announced
its servers had been hacked
and that same day roger stone called
donald trump on trump's personal
telephone line
on august 2nd 2016 stone called trump
and they chatted for 10 minutes
after that talk roger stone then told
conspiracy theorist and radio host
jerome corsai
to get someone in london to go talk to
julian assange the wikileaks co-founder
who was then living
in the embassy of ecuador while he
fought extradition
two days later on august 4th corsi sent
roger stone an email informing him that
assange was planning two more document
releases to damage hillary clinton
one of those releases would be in
october to have maximum impact on the
november election
course i told stone that quote hackers
were working to make it happen
during august the trump campaign staffer
rick gates who later pleaded guilty to
lying to fbi agents
had conversations with stone about the
wikileaks document releases
gates was also present when donald trump
had a telephone call with stone
after the call trump told gates more
information was planned
trump's lawyer michael cohen also
convicted of federal crimes
heard trump on the phone with stone who
allegedly told trump what wikileaks was
doing
trump campaign manager paul manafort
also convicted of federal crimes
told investigators that donald trump
told him to keep in touch with stone for
more information about wikileaks
now despite roger stone's links to
donald trump the president claimed
amnesia about whether he had any
conversations with stone during the
summer of 2016.
shortly after telling mueller's team
that he couldn't remember any
conversations in written answers
donald trump blasted witnesses that he
perceived as
flipping on him and trump praised stone
for his bravery in refusing to
snitch on trump and the trump campaign
the mueller report noted that trump's
actions towards stone's support and
inference that he was offering stone and
other witnesses rewards for not
providing damaging testimony
rewards like pardons after trump tweeted
about stone's bravery and the
treachery of snitches roger stone lied
to the house intelligence committee
those lies were particularly brazen
roger stone claimed he didn't have
anything in writing pertaining to
assange in reality he had hundreds of
documents he said he got the information
about wikileaks from talk show host
randy credico
when actually he got the information
from jerome corsai and perhaps vice
versa this predictably sent
investigators on a wild goose chase
looking for information from
credico the real intermediary coreside
never testified before the house
intelligence committee because
potentially stone lied and they didn't
know about corsi's involvement
roger stone also said he didn't have
communications with anyone from the
trump campaign when he actually talked
with manafort gates
bannon and trump and it turns out that
roger stone also had email conversations
with corsi and credico despite telling
congress that he wasn't an email guy now
as a federal judge
noted when stone was eventually
sentenced stone obstructed congress's
ability to know
what actually happened and potentially
led to the destruction of much of the
material roger stone actually had in his
possession
and stone pressured randy credico to go
along with stone's made up stories on
april 9 2018 in an email chain about
stone's testimony
roger stone wrote to credico i'm going
to take that dog away from you not a
thing you can do about it either because
you are a weak broke piece of
and stone also told credico to quote
prepare to die
now although credico said he did not
believe stone would actually steal his
dog or hurt him directly
he was worried that stone's comments
would encourage others to hurt him and
his family
stone even suggested that those
testifying regarding the wikileaks
information should pull a frank
pentanjali
to prevent contradicting his earlier
testimony pentangle was a character from
the godfather part 2
who lied to congress about organized
crime in order to save don corleone from
a perjury charge
i uh i never know spoiler
the character later slits his wrists in
prison now eventually some of stone's
lies were discovered and the doj
prosecuted
him during stone's trial the government
admitted for the first time that stone
may have discussed wikileaks with donald
trump during the summer of 2016.
and rick gates testified that he was in
a limousine with trump on their way to
laguardia airport
when trump talked on the phone with
stone about the emails
this information was apparently redacted
from the mueller report and was not made
public
until the stone trial it directly
contradicts president trump's statement
to robert mueller that quote
i do not recall discussing wikileaks
with stone nor do i recall being aware
of mr stone having discussed wikileaks
with individuals associated with my
campaign of course it's not clear and we
may never know as to whether stone was
lying to prevent the information of the
fact that the president had discussed
the wikileaks email hacks before they
were released
or whether there was more information
that is not yet public
that was even worse than this particular
scandal and now
roger stone has allegedly been rewarded
with a commutation
of his sentence now i say allegedly
because there's some really weird stuff
going on
and uh before we get into the actual
pardon power and what that means and
what the president can do to commute
someone's sentence and now questions
have arisen as to whether president
trump's clemency covers only roger
stone's prison time
or also his probation and the u.s
probation office has raised questions
about the commutation
itself so at the time of this video no
one has actually seen this
supposed commutation of roger stone's
sentence and we don't actually know
exactly what it covers
now apart from that legal weirdness
you'll also hear some individuals refer
to the crimes that roger stone was
convicted of
as being mere process crimes and
therefore
they're not really particularly
important crimes in fact
senator lindsey graham has basically
said that he's fine with a pardon
because stone was merely convicted of
process crimes
generally a process crime in this
context is a pejorative used to
say that the crime only came about uh as
a result of the legal process
itself these include things like perjury
obstruction of justice making false
statements and
failure to appear in court now as a
lawyer i find this particularly galling
because
process crimes can undermine the
rule of law as much if not more than
other quote non-process crimes because
if you can
get away with mucking around with the
justice system itself the
justice system will stop working why is
lying to law enforcement agents illegal
when a person isn't under oath because
it impedes the search for evidence and
the truth when witnesses lie they
obstruct the officer's ability to find
evidence obstruction
of justice obstructs justice it's right
there in the title it lets witnesses
manipulate the process
in sending agents in the wrong direction
and enabling the destruction of evidence
itself
it's kind of hard to square the idea of
being in favor of law and order
if you are not in favor of these
quote process crimes and thinking that
people should be able to get away with
lying to law enforcement agencies
obstructing justice
and intimidating witnesses so let's talk
about the formal constitutional pardon
power
donald trump has long been obsessed with
pardon power he has stated that he
more or less believes it gives him
unlimited constitutional authority to do
people favors he's even suggested that
he could pardon himself
but what is the pardon power is donald
trump right that it gives him
total power to commute and pardon people
for federal crimes
well under article 2 section 2 of the
u.s constitution the president was given
the
power to grant reprieves and pardons for
offenses against the united states
except in cases of impeachment
the supreme court case of ex party
garland established the contours of the
president's pardon authority
garland involved a presidential pardon
given by president andrew johnson who
pardoned thousands of confederate
soldiers for their
arguable crimes against american
participating in the civil war
however congress then passed a law
disbarring lawyers who were members of
the confederate government
augustus garland was a confederate
senator and a lawyer who claimed that
the law was a bill of attainder in an
ex-post-facto law that punished him
for a crime that he had already been
pardoned for the supreme court ruled for
garland and this ruling established two
key principles
first the president has full power to
pardon anyone of all federal crimes
either before
during or after prosecution the pardon
clears the individuals of any
consequences that they may have
arisen from the action from which they
were being punished
and second laws may not be established
that would punish someone
after the fact of the pardon this
prevents congress from passing a law
punishing someone who the president
actually pardoned and
commutations are another power granted
by article 2 section 2 and that's what
the reprieve referred to in the text
refers to unlike pardons which formally
forgive the individual the crimes and
restore what may have been lost through
the conviction
a commutation just ends the person's
sentence roger stone received a
commutation
at least allegedly in the white house
statement announcing the commutation the
white house indicated that a commutation
was chosen rather than a pardon
because stone does not concede his guilt
and will challenge his conviction on
appeal
now the commutation of stone sentence
has made a lot of people mad on both
sides of the aisle
even including andrew mccarthy who
writes for the national review which is
incredibly conservative and incredibly
pro-trump he got caught up in a
very politicized investigation and when
you lose andrew mccarthy you can bet
that your actions are pretty far
outside the overton window so as a
result a lot of people have started
talking about
limits on the president's pardon power
and in fact there are
some limits on the president's powers
and since the constitutional text only
mentions
reprieves and pardons for offenses
against the united states the president
can only pardon people for federal
criminal
acts people convicted of violating state
law can only seek clemency from their
governors
the pardon power also has nothing to do
with civil cases the president
cannot remove federal civil liability
for things like damages
there's also a legal consensus that the
president cannot pardon himself
after he has been impeached and removed
theoretically the president can only
pardon someone for crimes that have
already occurred in other words the
president cannot pardon people for
conspiracy that is still in process and
ongoing
this was established in ex party garland
because the decision specified that the
power
may be exercised at any time after the
commission of a crime we could get into
a deep argument here about whether roger
stone's crimes against united states are
actually part of an ongoing conspiracy
with president trump
and others but that would probably lead
us back to the text of article 2 section
2
what does it mean that the president's
power to pardon is limited by
impeachment you might recall that the
pardon clause says that the president
has the power to grant reprieves and
pardons for offenses against the united
states except in cases of
impeachment it simply says impeachment
rather than impeachment and
conviction and traditionally we have
assumed that the phrase except in cases
of impeachment means that a president
cannot use the pardon to
stop an impeachment this has been the
prevailing view for hundreds of years
mostly due to a book written by supreme
court justice joseph story in 1833
but detractors of this theory point out
that story did not have madison's notes
from the constitutional convention
which are considered some of the most
important sources of information for
what the framers actually thought
and story's interpretation gives
significant weight to the way that the
pardon power was used in
english common law under this view
president trump obviously could not
pardon himself to stop the house from
impeaching him
however there are two other
interpretations of this clause that have
become relevant recently
first it could mean that the president's
pardon power is suspended after the
house votes to impeach
james madison felt that a strong
congress would realize that the
president was conspiring to commit
treason impeach and remove him for
averting the crisis
madison said quote if the president be
connected in any suspicious manner with
any persons and there be grounds to
believe he will shelter himself
the house of representatives can impeach
him they can suspend him when suspected
and the power of pardoning will devolve
to the vice president
now a second interpretation of the text
also drawn from madison's words is that
the president can't pardon people
connected with the articles of
impeachment here the emphasis
is on the first part of madison's quote
if the president be connected
in any suspicious manner with any
persons so does this mean that the
president
cannot pardon people with whom he
conspired well while it's possible that
a supreme court could interpret the
pardon clause that way
odds are the supreme court would
probably say that the president
has uh that kind of power even though
that seems like a pretty reasonable
limit on presidential pardon power
in truth the supreme court is likely to
find that that's just a political
question
and that if people aren't happy with the
president
pardoning co-conspirators then they can
simply
vote him out of office or the house and
senate can
vote to impeach him out of office for
the act
of the pardon itself well it's true that
the text does not say
impeachment and conviction this
interpretation has never been tried in
court
and madison and other drafters of the
constitution offered impeachment as a
compromise
a way of checking the president's
executive powers but the impeachment
process has been used so sparingly that
we just don't know exactly what the
drafters of the constitution thought and
how it should be applied in these
particular circumstances and it's
unlikely that the supreme court is going
to seriously curtail
the president's pardon power which has
been used a lot more frequently than the
uh impeachment so given that this
doesn't sound great is there anything
that we can do about it the short answer
is
not really the only real check on pardon
power is through impeachment the
democrats could argue that trump's use
of the
pardon power is in this case impeachable
itself and try to argue that republicans
in the senate should vote to convict and
remove him from power but
that seems incredibly unlikely and
rather than going through another round
of
impeachment house speaker nancy pelosi
wants to pass legislation limiting the
president's pardon powers
this is an abusive power that the
president is again trying to manipulate
federal law enforcement to serve his
political interests
her proposal tracks the suggestion of
legal scholars who believe that the word
impeachment should mean that the
president's co-conspirators shouldn't
get a pardon or reprieve
but if congress passes a law limiting
the president's constitutional powers
it would probably be unconstitutional if
the supreme court
doesn't believe that that interpretation
of the pardon clause
is accurate remember the constitution
trumps any law that congress can pass
so in reality it would probably require
a constitutional amendment to change the
meaning of that text
now roger stone may be a dirty trickster
and he may have conspired with wikileaks
who
may have conspired with the russian gru
to destroy our democracy
but all this could have been avoided if
the dnc had used a little email security
now we should all back up our files but
to back them up without
security is almost as bad as asking the
russians to hack your political opponent
russia if you're listening i hope you're
able to find the 30 000 emails
that are missing which is why you should
use backblaze for backing up your
files all of backblaze's files are
stored on their secure data centers with
24-hour staff
biometric security and redundant power
backblaze is a cloud storage solution
that's both easy to use and affordable
starting at just six dollars per month
they've restored over 50 billion files
and they've got over an exabyte of data
storage
you can back up almost anything and you
can restore your files anywhere their
mobile apps give you access to your
files on the go so you can directly
download them or you can even restore
your files by mail
just purchase a restore via hard drive
and they will overnight fedex it to you
and after you restore all of your data
to another device you can then return
the hard drive to them for a refund
backblaze has unlimited data backup at a
fixed price and you can receive a fully
featured 15 day trial at backblaze.com
legaleagle again you can back up
unlimited data for free by clicking on
the link in the description
or going to backblaze.com legaleagle and
clicking on that link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis
should we amend the constitution to
remove the president's pardon power
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all my other analyses about legal
issues raised by kovid donald trump bill
barr
and so much more unfortunately so click
on this playlist and i'll see you
in court